some artists say that suffering is
necessary to create meaningful art but
there have to be limits right getting
mauled by a lion or driving a truck off
a cliff it's a kind of suffering that
seems to be reserved exclusively for
those whose art is a Hollywood film and
for better and worse these movies were
among the most hazardous to the health
of the cast and crew Waterworld while
it's seen today as something of a
curiosity 1995's Waterworld was a
spectacularly misguided career de
railing failure for Kevin Costner the
most expensive film ever made at the
time it baffled audiences with its
bizarre mythology and an even tone and
as might be expected from a film that
takes place on a world covered in ocean
the seafaring shoot was more than a
little hazardous and nearly killed
several members of the cast and crew
every day in pleasantness included
seasickness and constant jellyfish
things one costly set sunk and the diver
suffered an almost lethal case of the
bends during the retrieval effort female
lead Jeanne Tripplehorn and a child
actress Tina mater Eno had to be rescued
by divers when their sailboat fell apart
and Costner was pummeled by raging winds
and sea water for more than half an hour
while suspended 40 feet in the air for a
stunt even one experienced that man
famous big wave surfer Bill Hamilton was
lost at sea while commuting to the chute
on a jetski
and had to be rescued by a production
helicopter the entire shoot was one
gigantic risk to life and limb or for a
film that well what do you say Joey in
true The Expendables 3 given the age of
the cast it stands to reason that the
Expendables films have dished out a few
injuries to its stars but the
Expendables 3 really seems to have it in
for its and usually old cast age
it's just the state of mind then 68
year-old Sylvester Stallone suffered a
scary fool that necessitated a metal
plate in his back which joined the one
in his neck from an injury suffered on
the set of the first film co-star
Antonio Banderas injured his knee in his
very first take but the production
reserved its worst mishap for Jason
Statham who drove his truck straight off
a dark drawing a rehearsal and into the
Black Sea everybody panicked except
Statham who calmly swam to safety as the
truck has sank into the depths still
Statham told Jimmy Fallon that he wasn't
nearly as calm headed as everyone
thought so like 60 feet at the bottom of
the Black Sea stuck in the mud singing
hang on a minute I'm going to get out of
this if this is how it ends while
Statham called it a nightmare instinct
kicked in and he made it out safely
co-star Terry Crews summed it up saying
Jason Statham is a true bad bad dude raw
if ever a film seemed specifically
designed to threaten the safety of
everyone involved its 1981's raw the
brainchild of actress Tippi Hedren and
her writer producer husband Noel
Marshall it's the story of a family
attacked by wild jungle animals trying
to stay in Africa and it was executed in
the most insane fashion imaginable
dismayed to find that you couldn't just
rent lions Hedren and Marshall bought a
ranch and began raising their own along
with tigers leopards cheetahs and even
African elephants but then they went
ahead and shut their movie right there
on the ranch with their own children
working with some of the most incredibly
dangerous animals on the planet Wow of
course the injuries piled up Hedren was
bitten on the head by a lion and
Marshall was bit so many times he
developed gangrene head Ren's daughter
Melanie Griffith received stitches to
her face and almost lost an eye after an
attack and a cinematographer almost lost
his entire scalp to a lion an injury
requiring over 200 stitches many of the
attacks made the final cut of the film
which wasn't given any kind of North
American release until 2015 years later
Hedren estimated the number of injuries
at over 100 and
called roar the most dangerous film ever
made in history Troy the 2004 war epic
Troy was one of the most expensive
lavishly staged films to ever be 7
differently perceived it's mostly
remembered today for the strange fate of
one of its stunt performers and for one
of the most coincidental injuries in
film history drawing a seam of many
extras stern's man George Camilleri
sustained a severe injury to his lower
leg acquiring surgery a couple weeks
later he was readmitted to the hospital
and quickly passed away from a pulmonary
thromboembolism a common complication
after an injury of his type the film
star Brad Pitt cast as Achilles also
somehow managed to interest characters
namesake tendon during the shoot
causing production to be shut down for
10 weeks hurricane Marty also damaged
some sets but Troy overcame all these
difficulties and arrives triumphantly in
theaters only to be met with a solid
thump jumper at the 2008 sci-fi thriller
jumper didn't cause any problems until
principal photography had wrapped but
when it did it was lethal set dresses
were tearing down exterior sets in the
middle of a cold Toronto winter when a
freakish mishap occurred a huge chunk of
sand on earth which was frozen to a wall
came unstuck striking three set dressers
six-year-old david ritchie didn't
survive and another man sustained
serious injuries to his head and
shoulders toronto police described it as
a fluke accident and the incident cast a
pall over the highly anticipated film
which unfortunately didn't score well
with anyone
xxx they goes without saying a xxx with
a dangerous film to make as the story of
an extreme sports badass who becomes a
secret government agent each stunt ramps
up the danger and the one spectacular
stunt unfortunately cost aerial stunt
coordinator Harry O'Conner his life as
director Rob Cohen McCowan's on the DVD
commentary now unfortunately right there
smacking into the bridge breaking his
neck and dying O'Connor stunt remained
in the completed film right up until the
point in which he doesn't clear the
structure
Cohen considered the stunt to be servo
team that he assigned it to a second
unit and to most of the casting crew had
already completed their work on the film
Resident Evil the final chapter
the
and evil series of films is the most
profitable video game to film series
adaptation of all time but 2016 Resident
Evil the final chapter proved to be just
as big a threat to life and limb as the
film's roving zombies stuntwoman olivia
jackson has suffered horrific injuries
when a camera rig failed to make way for
her during a motorcycle stunt requiring
her to be put into a medically induced
coma her list of injuries were extensive
and gory including having her skin torn
from her face a severed neck artery a
shattered shoulder blade a collapsed
lung a brain bleed and the loss of a
left arm and fortunately the incident
didn't seem to lead to increase caution
on the set only a couple months later
crew member Ricardo Cornelius was
crushed when a Humvee slipped off of a
platform and pinned him to a wall
reports of the accidents leaked only
after the film was completed production
Apocalypse Now
perhaps no film shoot wasn't legendarily
taxing on everyone involved as Francis
Ford Coppola smashed a piece of
pocalypse now that everyone survived its
filming is nothing short of a miracle
shooting on location in Vietnam the
production was beset by tropical disease
and the natural disasters that wiped out
entire sets but those were the least of
their problems Coppola was running a
drug field a psychologically abusive
madhouse that was out of control from
the very beginning lead actor Martin
Sheen stepped straight into the worst
possible environment for him at the time
in the middle of a personal breakdown
and Maya deep in alcoholism Sheen was
fed a steady diet of alcohol and abuse
by Coppola who brought out the darkness
and Sheen's character by screaming at
the actor and telling him how evil he
was sometimes ego stood for
he's the first one he admitted Sheen
would eventually have a heart attack
yet somehow continued on with the
production Coppola himself lost 100
pounds and the Dennis Hopper stumbled
through the chute on an insane daily
regimen of a case of beer half gallon of
rum and the three ounces of cocaine
actor Sam bottoms has spent the entire
year long chute tripping on LSD hopper
later commented asked anybody who was
out there we all felt like we fought the
war ben-hur 1959's Ben Hur is well known
for its iconic chariot race scene which
was filmed on the largest set ever
constructed at that time covering 18
acres it was also at the time the most
expensive single scene in history at
four million dollars and took over ten
grueling weeks the action-packed
sequence was virtually unprecedented in
cinema employing a camera car that put
viewers right in the middle of the
chaotic horse-drawn action most
impressive was this dangerous scene
where Ben Hur is nearly thrown from his
chariot the stunt was performed by Joe
cannerts who landed so hard that he
really was pitched violently off the
chariots and in between its two horses
well it turned him a complete him bring
over the chariot and he managed to hang
with one head and get a hold of the hit
trail and turn to flip off into this
pinna war he sustained only a cut on his
chin but to this day rumors persist that
studio MGM had covered up the death of a
stunt performer simply because it's so
hard to believe nobody died filming that
scene the Conqueror the second-to-last
film produced by Howard Hughes would
haunt him for the rest of his life the
Conqueror was a big-budget flopper
featuring a woefully miss cast John
Wayne as the unintentionally comedic
Genghis Khan during the last years of
his life
Hughes bought up all the prints he could
find and watch the film obsessively
perhaps mortified by its failure or
perhaps wracked with guilt for having
basically executed the entire cast the
film was shot on location in the Utah
desert directly downwind from the area
where the US government detonated over a
hundred atomic bombs between 1951 and
1962 an atomic bomb at the Nevada Test
Site 140 miles to the west but it sold
stuff to st. George
11 was detonated in 1953 alone
year before the Conqueror began
production the risks of nuclear fallout
were not terribly well understood at the
time and the Atomic Energy Commission
declared the area completely safe
they were staggeringly horrifyingly
wrong in the decades following the
film's production no fewer than 90 cast
and crew passed away from cancer
including Wayne lead actress Susan
Hayward and director dick Powell a
subsequent study concluded that Cold War
air and nuclear testing had killed at
least 11,000 Americans when you saw the
tragedy in terms of the families sorry
dr. arc since 1990 Congress has paid two
billion dollars to residents of the
fallout area in which the Conqueror was
filmed it was one of Hollywood's biggest
turkeys it killed one of its biggest
stars and it just may have finished the
job of driving Howard Hughes totally
insane thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you're loved too
[Music]